hey everyone its micromotor flows and
welcome to today's presentation on using
order flow to find price rejection and
how to profit from it and my goal for
you today in this presentation is to
teach you what is price rejection and
show you how to profit from it I'll
explain why price rejection allows you
to catch trends when they begin and will
show you how to see price rejection
using order flow now for those that
don't know who I am my name is Mike
Balto's and I'm the owner and trader at
order flows calm I started it in 2015
now the reason why I want you guys to
know my background is so that you know
that I come from an actual trading
background you know I wasn't like a
college student that just said in a dorm
room reading books and all of a sudden
say I figured out the secret to the
market no this is what I did for a
living
and you could see I started on the CMA
floor as a runner literally started at
the bottom with Dean Witter this was in
the early 90s then when Globex and
project day and night max Axess started
becoming used by the futures traders on
the floor and the desks and the
brokerage firms I left the trading floor
and I worked upstairs on the Dean Witter
Reynolds upstairs trading desk basically
I was the Globex trader so I did that
for three years and I trade it all
literally all the markets that were
available on Globex at that time as well
as all the other futures markets that
were available overseas and after that I
left to go to ETF man which is the big
English trading firm I spent two years
there as a global macro trader after man
I left and went to work at Commerce Bank
I spent three years there as a license
Urich trader your ex trader I traded
bones bobbles chats - zero stocks and I
traded all those against the US the US
counterpart products I spent four years
at Cargill the big American privately
held a trading company which is actually
one of the largest companies in the
United States you know they account for
about 30% of u.s. grain exports 25% of
meat exports but they literally trade
everything you could imagine you know
energies interest rates as well as
commodities and they traded globally as
well and I even went to Singapore to set
up a trading desk when the exchange
closed in Singapore when the floor
trading closed in Singapore we need
upstairs trading desk and I went out
there to set that up and I spent eight
years as a vice president of Futures
Trading at JPMorgan now this was an
actual trading job you know I spent all
day on the trading desk I'd come in at
you know 5:00 5:30 in the morning leave
at 4:30 5:00 o'clock at night and wasn't
sitting in some corner office looking at
spreadsheets or anything like that no I
was on the desk
pounding out trades on the on the system
there so that's my background so you can
understand you know this is what I did
for a living this is how I paid my bills
and and survived you know so again it
wasn't something I just did in the
part-time no this is what I did as a job
as a career and what I'm presenting here
is what I've developed for myself and
built my trading career on I hope you
can find things that you can use or
modify and adapt for your own trading
again I don't want to think you have to
become a clone of me that that's not
going to happen and I don't recommend it
honestly you know what you have to do is
you take the parts that make sense to
you that you can apply in your own
trading and you apply it again I'm not
saying that you have to follow what I
say just because I say it you have to
evaluate everything you come across
whether it's from me or from other
speakers here an investor inspiration
and decide if it's going to help you if
not you reject it and you move on you
find the next thing that's going to help
you you know trading is like a puzzle
all right you can't fit you know the the
round peg into the square hole all right
you need the round peg to go into the
round hole and if you're trying to trade
in a way that's not compatible with you
you're not going to be very good at it
or very successful at it so let me be
clear you know with trading you got to
make decisions and that's what trading
is about you know order flow is not
necessarily a red light green light
trading system you know some people like
to think it is but it's really it's not
when you understand order flow you're
gonna understand what the market is
doing and your decisions your trading
decisions are gonna become very clear so
before I begin you know let me just go
through a brief disclaimer you know this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security
or lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading in only those with
sufficient risk Apple should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
you know the reason why I go through a
disclaimer and every every presentation
it's cuz I do want you to realize there
is risk involved in trading you know
it's not risk-free if it was risk-free
everybody would do it and we'd all be
driving around in Nice fancy cars and
you know going to the Yacht Club or the
golf club on the weekends but no trading
takes work for a lot of people yes I
know there's gonna be some people there
there's that small minut percentage
where things just come naturally to them
you know almost like you know like we're
sports stars you know they just have a
natural talent for it but in general the
vast overwhelming majority of traders it
they gotta work at it and there's no
shame in working at it and trying to
learn and that's what I like to do these
presentations for is because I want you
to open your eyes to new ideas and
hopefully you know you can take that and
and make some money with it so the first
thing I talk about is what is price
rejection and how to profit from it so
you know I call it the number one reason
why traders fail okay but I've got
several number one reasons actually but
one of the main reasons if not the
number one reason traders fail is is
they think all prices are created equal
and this goes back to indicator based
price based trading you know most people
you know when it come to training they
throw a bunch of indicators on the
screen and they go from there and an
indicator basically takes you know the
traded price and puts it into a formula
and comes out with something but not all
prices are created equally not all
prices are the same and this is
especially true when markets make highs
or lows you know let me just give you an
example you know if you think the market
hits a high and trades 3 contracts and
then sells off versus a market that
makes a high and trades 3,000 contracts
and then sells off it's it has different
meanings okay you know if it trades a
new high in trades you know 60 contracts
comes off that's going to be different
then if you trade a high and 3000
contracts you know traded at the high
and then comes off you know it can be
sign of resistance it could be a sign of
you know just the market pausing and
that's gonna go back up or it could be a
sign of you know lack of buyers so it's
got different meanings and you know I've
got to realize right the market exists
to facilitate trade it's gonna find
price levels we're both buyers and
sellers can trade and be happy in other
words it's looking for a fair price
that's what the market is doing is
looking for a price where traders are
happy to transact at a price level so in
order to find the spare price level the
markets gonna go up and go down all
right it's gonna find a fair price level
it's gonna trade there that markets
gonna move you know perception of value
is gonna change then the market is going
to find a new fair price level that's
what makes the market go up and down and
you know market will move up and up as
traders buy and buy however as the
market reaches its high price level the
level where traders think it's too
expensive to buy then buying activity
becomes less selling we'll start to take
over in the market starts to drop and
the opposite is true when the market is
moving lower and lower as traders sell
and sell the market reaches the point
where prices are just too cheap to sell
anymore and selling activity becomes
less and less buying takes over and the
market starts to rally give you an
example okay say you want to say you
have I don't know winter jackets okay
and you know you bought a bunch of
winter jackets thinking hey you know
it's going to be cold this winter so I'm
gonna buy these jackets and I could sell
them for a high price well the winter is
mild all the sudden you're sitting in
mid January with it with a boat
truckload of winter jackets and you're
gonna say well I gotta get my money back
so you start selling them and you start
lowering the price lowering the price
and people are buying them okay but as
you lower the price you start thinking
hey you know what I'm losing too much
money so you start you know you want to
recover back some so you sell less and
less and then finally like it's just too
cheap I'm just gonna hold these put them
in the put them in storage in the next
year I could sell them at a higher price
okay that's where you know that that's
in a market that's selling off now think
about you know a support level and a
good example is this
is you got a paper towel you hold it
under a sink right then you turn on the
sink the water is running and it's a
constant you know think of the water is
the selling pressure it's a constant
you're holding the paper towel well
eventually it's gonna break through that
support and it's gonna keep going down
now if you're holding the paper towel
there but instead of you know having a
constant stream of water coming down you
slowly turn off the water you know where
it's just coming down instead of at a
constant stream it's just drip drip drip
well that level that paper towel is
gonna hold why is because the selling
pressure which was the water going down
is becoming lesser okay and if it's
gonna be coming lesser if selling
pressure is gonna become lesser and
eventually dry up then theoretically the
market is going to rally so you know
most people you know when they search
price rejection on the internet you know
they find a chart like this and you know
like here the guy has a swing level
right that's that line horizontal line
going across then he's got you know the
candlestick chart where you know it's
kind of a shooting star here which
shoots up through the level comes back
down and this and you know these
Internet analysts will say well that's a
price rejection you know because we have
a level here and price rejected that
level well you don't know that prices
why that price is rejecting that level
is it price rejection because there's no
more interest in the market going higher
or is it price rejection because there's
a lot of resistance up here I mean it
could be a big seller here whacking it
you know just sitting here waiting to
you know hit the sell button when people
start bidding it up whereas it's gonna
have a different meaning if it's breaks
through there and the buying gets lesser
and lesser and finally the buying stops
and it starts drying down because if
this is a support or sorry resistance
level and you break up through there and
you got a big seller sitting up here you
know ready to hit the sell button well
what's going to happen when he's you
know he sells okay the market comes off
but if you come back up people test it
again he sells some more comes off a
little bit a third time you come back up
and he's only got a little bit left to
sell and then finally the buyers realize
that and they start buying it up and all
of a sudden that sellers know
longer their markets gonna rally okay
but if it's coming up into this area and
you just have your normal order flow for
example but buying isn't as strong
anymore so let's say you know you fifty
contracts are bought on the offer than
twenty then ten and then five and then
that's it you know the last buyer has
bought the market's going to reverse and
go down because you don't have that
buying pressure anymore so you know it's
there's different ways to look at this
and unless you're looking at the volume
you're not going to know so we've got to
remember and right no market can move in
one direction forever at some points
we're gonna become too expensive or too
cheap and at some point price rejection
appears have traders have basically
taken the stance and said you know it's
too expensive or too cheap candlesticks
okay you know when candlesticks came out
or didn't come out in the 90s but you
know when they became popular in America
in the early 90s you know I jumped all
over them you know a visual person I I'm
someone that believes the the mind can
process images at a much faster rate
than text or numbers and you know
there's certain candlesticks that under
candlestick analysis are price rejection
candles you know you got your hammers
you've got your shooting stars got
doji's to some people but you know the
often times you see the charts like this
where they circle it well you have a
shooting star up here or why haven't
they circled this one that failed you
know this one is borderline but you know
they still have it circled okay but then
they'll say well you know we would come
down here we tested these two levels and
both times you know it rejected these
levels well why did it reject those
levels is it because there's a strong
buyer down here that every time the
market tries to push down here buyers
come back out and buy it up well that's
not price rejection that's price support
okay but if you come down in here and
you know the selling is weaker the
second time that's a sign of price
rejection and then the market goes up
now I know some people are gonna say
well I don't really give a if you
know it's price rejection or price
support all I cares if it's going to
touch this level and rally
well okay you know good on you you know
the
and you know I hope you're successful
because you know if me I'm more of a
purist in the sense that I want to
understand what's happening in the
market and make the proper trading
decision based on it you know because if
if I know there's support here and we're
gonna come down in here I'm gonna be
watching okay I'm not gonna
automatically think that we're gonna hit
the support level and rally back up if I
see we hit the support level rally up
come back down selling is a little
weaker and then we come back down again
selling is is weaker here then yeah I'm
gonna think it's gonna rally but if I
come back down and I see selling is
strong and we're going to look like
we're gonna take out this support level
I'm not gonna think the markets gonna
rally instead I think the markets going
to sell off so a price rejection is a
difficult concept for some people to
understand because you know they don't
look at volume right they just look at a
normal bar chart and they treat every
price level that's traded as the same
they don't take into account volume but
the way to understand it I always say
he's got to put the market activity into
what you do in your everyday life you
know in the grocery store when you're
shopping for groceries in the jewelry
store you know if you're if you're
buying something nice for yourself or
for your wife and even in dating right
you remember there's always a story of
the prettiest girl in school doesn't
always get asked out to the dance
because she's too pretty so people get
you know rejected before they even get
rejected you know they like
psychologically they think well she's
not gonna say yes to me because she's
pie already has a date so they don't ask
you know you go to a jewelry store you
know you want to buy a fancy diamond
ring or something that's worth a hundred
thousand well majority of buyers are
going to reject it one day it's too
expensive for them they just don't have
the money and you know for it maybe
handful of people that can afford a
hundred thousand dollar diamond ring you
know they'll look at it and yeah you
know it's probably just a little bit too
expensive more than I want to pay so
they're not going to do it they're not
gonna pay for it so as you go up that
triangle of available buyers it gets a
lesser and lesser so people are
rejecting those higher prices
grocery-store the same thing you know if
you got your choices with groceries
stores you can go to Walmart you go to
Meijer you can go to Target you can go
to you know jewel or you know whatever
your local grocery store is and
sometimes you know they they have the
same thing but it's got different prices
well you're not going to buy like the
the the watermelon at at a little Meijer
if it's five dollars for one watermelon
but you're gonna but you might be
interested to buy it if it's you know at
Walmart for three dollars you know
you're gonna reject the higher price so
that happens all the time
even in grocery stores you don't realize
it but what you're doing you know people
say you're shopping around but you know
what you're doing is actually rejecting
the higher priced items or where you
know you can get it for a lower price
and price rejection is a fundamental
aspect of the market that's overlooked
by many traders because they can't
define it and like I said you know with
the order flow you can define it it's
because you're looking at the volume
otherwise you're just guessing that's
why you know people don't really talk
about price rejection all everyone likes
to talk about is support and resistance
because it's easy to draw a line on a
chart where the part market has touched
two or three times and say well this is
support and this is resistance when
sometimes it's not you know and like I
said you know some people don't are
gonna say I don't care you know all I
care about is if the market hit there
two or three times you know that's I'm
gonna take a trade based off it but yeah
what I'm trying to say the point I'm
trying to make is you can make a better
trading decision if you just take a
second to look at the volume that's
going through there is it lighter than
normal or is it consistent with you know
normal trading that's going on if it's
consistent with normal trading that's
going on not all support or all
resistance is going to hold it's not in
the if in a thing where every time we
come down to that price level it's gonna
hold forever no at some point it's going
to break through so if we're trading you
know average to above-average volume
when you test a support or resistance
level you know the second third or even
fourth time eventually gonna get through
that level but if you test that level
the second or third time and the volume
is a lot lighter the selling pressure is
a lot lighter if you're coming into a
support area
there's a very good chance that the
markets going to bounce up off that
level it's not gonna break through it
because the selling pressure is just not
there to move it through that support
level so when you're able to identify
when prices are being rejected you can
position yourself in the direction of
the ensuing move you know in price
rejection often occurs at market highs
and market lows and more importantly
price rejection can also appear just
after a high or just after all always
made and I'll get into another aspect of
it is to see it in a move also it
happens in a move you know in in as if
market is moving in a direction you see
signs in the volume that you know it's
rejecting the lower prices if a market
is moving up or if a markets moving down
you could see there's times where it's
rejecting the higher prices when it
tries to come back so if you can
determine a higher low is being made
that's going to present you a great
trading opportunity to catch a potential
big move that's what we all want to do
we want to catch a big moves so price
rejection as moves start so this is the
euro currency and it's a five-minute
chart you can see down here where this
arrow is there's signs of price
rejection in the order flow that's the
you know and right before the market put
in this big move up to new highs you
know 143 30 32 all the way up to you
know 114 68 there's another example
there's also the euro currency you know
you got your swing high up here signs of
price rejection then you start coming
off you got two more signs of price
rejection on the way down so say you're
not convinced yet yeah you know what
Mike you're crazy I don't think that's
price rejection up there then what
happens on the move down you sort of hit
this area where you start going sideways
but at the tops of these bars you're
seeing some signs of price rejection and
then the market sells off and again just
after the high is made you know you hit
your high up here then the next bar it
tries to circle back up there maybe make
a run at that high to take it out but
you're seeing signs of price rejection
then the market just sells off from
there so price rejection what is it it's
when high prices are rejected by buyers
as being too expensive
and buyers don't want to overpay for
something no one wants to over pays for
something you know whether it's in real
life or whether it's in trading in the
markets
yeah and low prices are rejected by
sellers as being too cheap and sellers
don't want to see to sell at such low
prices again you know think of it in
real life terms you know if you're
trying to sell something right say you
want to to sell your you know your used
desk you know on Facebook you know
there's Facebook markets is you know
it's a great place to buy stuff that's
used this great example you know you
want to sell your used desk on there and
you think it's worth $100 you put it up
there nobody wants to buy it you know
and maybe some guy comes in well I'll
give you 20 bucks for it well you're not
gonna sell it to him because you think
that's too cheap and you know that
that's a microcosm of the whole bid you
know the bid-ask market right there you
know you might say ad and go back and
forth with him but you know maybe you
got no interest maybe nobody even comes
in is interested in your desk because
they think oh it's too expensive I don't
wanna buy it so no one bids and you
lower to 80 still nothing you know like
what do I do now you know do I sell out
at 50 bucks or do you think god you know
what 50 bucks I'm better off just
keeping it you know that's that's price
rejection on the downside all right if
you know so you collect baseball cards
and there's a card that you want but
it's you know very expensive yeah you're
not gonna buy it because it's too
expensive you can wait for maybe for it
to come down before you come in and
start buying it so price rejection the
second thing I talk about with price
rejection is why price rejection allows
you to catch trends when they begin and
you know every trader has access to the
same information I always say this it's
how you use the information that makes
the difference yeah so you know this
information and the information in the
order flow volume footprint chart this
information everyone has access to you
don't need level-2 level-3 data you just
need your regular data feed from the
exchange which goes through your broker
or you go through kinetic or through IQ
feed or whoever saw a data feed you're
using it it comes with the basic
subscription you don't need level two
you don't need to pay extra for that
and you know so it boggles my mind
sometimes why people don't use this
information you know it's and instead of
trying to guess the future direction of
the market you just listen and and see
what the market is telling you the
direction is going to be and you trade
it you know it's it's like you know the
best thing you know there's a scene and
in I forgot what it was one of those not
Iron Man with all those vengers movies
you know or Captain America you know
Thor comes in and then you know you have
Iron Man there and Iron Man gets all
upset because Thor took his brother Loki
but you know so Captain America well
does the Iron Man well what's your plan
of attack he says well that's my plan
attack and it's like what's your trading
plan well my plan is to trade you know
rather than sit around wait for
confirmation you know I'm gonna try to
try and wait or guess the future
direction because I got a certain
pattern for me no you got a trade I mean
that's what traders do no firms don't
hire traders to sit around and and wait
for confirmation and wait for trades to
hire traders to trade and make money for
them and you know what comes to trend
trading we've all heard these sayings
you know the trend is your friend trade
in the direction of the trend you know
let your winners run you know we've all
heard those and more and and those are
solid pieces of information you know I
admit you know I I subscribe to those
sayings as well you know I'm not here to
dispel those I mean those are a common
basic tenets of trading got a trade in
direction of the trend and you gotta let
your winners run you'll cut your losers
and let your winners run and that's
where price rejection can help you you
know if the trend is your friend well
you want to get in on the trend as early
as possible all right you don't want to
necessarily wait for confirmation and
give up extra ticks or extra pips in the
market you want to get in as soon as
they're signs of price rejection you
know you can see this this low here you
got signs the price rejection this high
signs of price rejection you don't need
to wait you know well I'm gonna wait for
a double bottom to form or a double top
to form to get short no I know there's a
that this high up here there's price
rejection I'm gonna get short I know
there's price rejection at this low I'm
gonna get long and then in the direction
of the trend say I'm long from this low
you know if I get a sign in here that
hey you know even though it's starting
to sell off they're still rejecting
these lower prices you can ride this
you know four more so how do you catch a
trend early well you have to identify a
market inflection point you know a point
where prices are being rejected is too
cheap or too expensive and again you
know you want to get in a SAP as soon as
possible and one of the ways is single
prints single prints is an easy way to
see price rejection in a bar and it's
used when taken in context of the market
in a hole okay and what is a single
print the single print occurs when the
last buyers have bought at a high or the
last sellers have sold at the low and
this was a piece of advice that I got
from Tom to mark you know one of the
great market analysts you know I think
you know in the last 30 years that you
know pie doesn't get as much recognition
as as you should because he actually
deals more on the institutional side but
you know he told me that when the last
buyer has bought the markets gonna not
go higher any more when the last seller
has sold the markets not gonna sell off
anymore and you have to realize these
areas of price rejection or some people
refer to them as price exhaustion you
know order flow analytics copy this you
know I released this in 2015 in the
first version of my order closed trader
software and now the most recent release
of order flow analytics they've added it
in there they call it single print
exhaustion I usually just referred to it
a single print by also we refer to it as
as rejection and what did we do is we
draw on the order flows trader software
we draw a box around the single print on
the red on the down candle on the red
bar it'll appear on the top appear on
the top on a green candle it'll be a
green box at the bottom of the bar now
now when I said you know you take it in
context of the market don't just think
well I got a single print I get short or
I get long take the overall market
context okay
and what do you have here you got a
market to trailin you got some single
prints price rejection okay you come
back up and make a new high at that new
high you got single print as you start
coming off single print single print
single print
this is interesting too because people
always ask me Mike you know I have my
own way of market analysis what how can
I use order flow or what piece of water
flow can I use to complement that you
know cuz what they want to do is they
want to refine their entries you find
their exits you know maybe they have a
way of finding support resistance you
know maybe they use fib numbers maybe
they get you know pivot levels from
someone and you know really what they
want to look for is is better entries or
better exits and you know how can they
use it and I often say use you know
start with single prints and see how
price reacts around a resistance level
you know if you have a resistance level
up here and you're seeing single print
single print single print single print
all right around that resistance level
you could be fairly confident in getting
short yeah you can say well the market
popped up here well you know sometimes
when you when you're trading a level and
the market is rallying doesn't turn
around right at the level it oftentimes
can overshoot that level just to touch
that's why it's called you know a
support and resistance level not a Swart
and resistance price but single prints
are great in that in that respect price
rejection is being too cheap you know
this sort of goes to what I was saying
about you know using it in the direction
of the trend I'm going to talk about
more this more in a minute is the other
markets moving up every time we sort of
come down here go sideways I think I
sign a price rejection in the market
makes another higher highs then you
start going sideways boom a single print
price rejection down here and the market
is rejecting these lower prices as it
tests it to try and go lower it's not
going lower and then the market keeps
you know going on up in that direction
so how do you trade in the direction of
the trend is you go with the momentum of
the market there often times there are
signs of price rejection as a move is
underway and you know think of it like a
boat right when you're driving a boat
you notice there's no brakes on a boat
you just don't stop the boat it still
has forward momentum but if you just
kill the engine a little bit you know
and you slow down
you know you might be you're still
making awake you know if you understand
boating you know you're still going
forward but you're sort of rejecting the
how to say it you know it's not the best
example but you know trends move with
momentum okay
and oftentimes as the market keeps
moving in that direction
it's got momentum and you can see signs
little trails little breadcrumbs so to
speak of price rejection in that move
and the good thing is you know when you
see those signs of price rejection
that's your confirmation that you're on
the right side of the trade when I say
confirmation you know waiting put you're
in the trade already and this just
reassures you that you're on the right
side of the trend you know lots of times
we get into trades and we think we're on
the right side but we're actually not
you know if you're along here and you
see these signs of price rejection hey
that's that's great you know if you're
short right so you say hey you know I
think this is swing high you get short
okay I got a sign a price rejection here
a bearish sign but then you run into
this and the market starts turning
around and you're like well you know I'm
gonna hold it a little bit no you get
out because the signs are no longer
there but if you're a long you know from
down below you know before this chart
started and you come in here you're like
well maybe should I get in shy stay in
shy stay out get out when you see a sign
of price rejection there that's that's
reassuring you okay stay long as you
start going up okay you can stay long as
you keep going higher get another
example you know you got your single
print down here at the low start
rallying okay hey I got a single print
that's good I got another single print
here you know as we hit this this first
down bar right you're going up you're
thinking oh my gosh we're starting to go
gonna sell off oh you better get out but
then you look okay I could see in the
volume I got a single print there okay
that's reassuring I can stay under then
you know you see some other things in
the order flow you see a prominent point
of control you see a stacked imbalance
and the market starts continuing on back
up and then even got another single
print here another single print there
just to confirm that you know what
you're on the right side you're going in
the right direction you know if you're
getting short off this oh my gosh I got
a double top here I better get short
well then you run into the single print
here that's probably not a good short
but you know a lot of people say what
you got to look left they say okay well
I came up here we tested this double top
and we're gonna sell off well no that's
what I'm telling you it's down here at
these lower levels prices being rejected
price rejection single prints and a
trend same thing right off the low this
is the low bar here you have a
divergence single print as you come up
here shot going sideways single print
and make new highs so how does see price
rejection using order flow well that's
what most people hear on this
presentation for us because they want to
see how they can use order flow to see
price rejection and there's a hard way
and there's easy way what's the hard
ways you can take years by sitting in
front of a trading screen and watching
the market day in day out without
blowing your brains out or throwing the
your computer off the window cuz trading
is boring honestly you guys sit in front
of a trading screen and you're not
making any money doing it you're gonna
lose interest you know you're gonna
start mines gonna start wandering and go
to Facebook go to whatever you know
Google or Drudge and your attention is
not going to be there now the easy way
is to use software that is gonna do the
analysis for you now the order flow is
trader software which I develop has
several tools that's gonna highlight
price rejection and I talked briefly
just earlier on single prints but
there's more advanced tools out there
the oracles ratio and price rejecter
software add-on now and I told you about
single prints finally being adopted by
some of the other software vendors out
there like overflowing analytics now the
ratio is also when I released the
original version of order flows trader
in 2015 the ratios was something that I
was the only one using because I was
only one I don't say I invented it but
you know maybe some other guy somewhere
around the world has invented it and you
know a couple years before me you never
told anyone but I was actually doing
this analysis in my head or on a
calculator when I go and you know the
math you know was not too difficult but
you know then the numbers were big that
was not as easy for me to figure out but
I had the ratios in the single prints in
in 2015
in the first version of Oracle's trader
we've since done a an upgrade to the
order flows trader earlier this year
where we've added in a few more
indicators to help you use in analyzing
the order flow and the order flows ratio
also you know copied by a lot of other
people and I don't mind people copying
my ideas and putting them out there but
you know some people are cool about it
they want to give me your name
recognition you know I don't need
monetary recognition per se but you know
say hey you know this is concept first
put forth by my cat over flows but you
know it just kills me sometimes when
people take this idea then they they try
to package it up into something fancy
like oh this is our order flow volume
Delta L goal and things like that or the
order flow volume ratio algo you know
they think that they throw in the word
Algol people always an algo I better buy
it you know you should really just learn
how to trade rather than just go buy
shiny objects out there and the price
rejecter software is an additional
software that just it runs also an intra
trader or what a normal bar chart but it
it reads the order flow doesn't deal
with the ratios it reads a different
part of the order flow to find price
rejection you know it deals with order
flow imbalances and price action so it's
is it's it's a further step in order
flow analysis so again let's just
briefly a single print occurs when
there's a single volume print volume
between 0 and 9 contracts at the bottom
bid side of a green candle which
indicates sellers in that bar have dried
up as the market was moving lower this
is a bullish single print the opposite
is true for a bearish single print the
top offer side has a volume between 0
and 9 at the top offer side this
indicates that buyers we're starting to
dry up the people have lost interest in
buying basically and again you know it's
gonna show it'll on the software when
you load the template it's going to take
the information that's available to
everybody right you don't need level 2
or level 3 information just your normal
data feed with bid-ask data
if you're using Interactive Brokers it's
not really recommended because they're
David their data the way it's it's sort
of aggregated on a time basis rather
than as trades occur
so single prints you know all the
information all the bid-ask what's trade
on the bid and was traded on the ask is
taken and the software takes it and puts
it into a nice easy to read format you
know so you can see single print so you
could see other things in there but what
I'm talking about right now is single
prints so I'm showing you a single print
single print single print single print
single print here here as the markets
moving higher now the next thing I'll
talk about is the ratios and this is a
prop tool that I created helped me see
where price rejection or support appears
in the order flow and ratios measure the
order flow occurring in a bar depending
on the ratio can mean price support or
it can mean price rejection and in this
presentation I'm gonna just talk about
the ratios that indicate price rejection
and every bar is going to have a ratio
okay and some indicate price rejection
some indicate price supports you know
the ratios that have no bearing one way
or the other which is actually the
majority of ratios on the chart is your
normal order full right markets facility
you know exists to facilitate trade
that's why markets were invented so
people can contribute and transfer the
risk and again you know when I see
people putting out you know copying some
ideas they don't explain it fully so you
don't really understand what you're
looking at and you know when you get my
software you know I explained it so you
know what you're looking at and can
understand and make a good decision so
there's different types of ratios you
know there's a big number ratio there's
a small number ratio and each one has a
different meaning so they're either
gonna be blue or black black ratios they
appear above the red candle or below a
green candle it's just your normal order
flow there's nothing special about that
bar in the order flow but blue numbers
above a red candle or blue numbers below
a green candle green is a bullish ratio
I'm sorry a blue number
below a green candle is a bullish ratio
a blue number above a red candle is a
bearish ratio and you see how oftentimes
the markets turned at a bar with a blue
number blue number blue number now here
no here no but you know that's
information in the order flow to help
you catch these market turning points
okay like I said you know sometimes the
market it has got black numbers right
that's just the normal order flow that's
going through just a normal trade being
facilitated but there's times in the
Oracle that things are very obvious and
that's what we try to highlight to you
with the ratios and as you can see here
right bullish ratio the markets going up
bearish ratio the markets going down
bearish ratio the market goes down
markets going back up you got a bullish
ratio price rejection again you know you
got a you got a high up here you got a
divergence so you got a new high with
negative Delta that's one of divergences
start coming off but then you go
sideways in here well at this point
you're thinking well what are we going
to do we're gonna go back up test that
higher we're gonna sell off you know as
a trader you got to make these decisions
you know some people will say oh I'm
gonna wait for confirmation I'm gonna
wait for the market to come back up here
then sell off or see if we reject that
price etc well you don't need to you can
trade all right you can see you got
price rejection price rejection price
rejection in the ratios and what happens
eventually the market sells off you know
this is a move from the 2867 area all
the way down a 28:57 area in the snps
okay again you know watch the ratios
watch where they appear here you got
your bullish ratio market goes up well
you'd even take it back here from the
beginning here you know infinity well
don't worry about that one for now but
you know okay so you got a bearish ratio
markets just going sideways they got
bullish ratio the market goes up bearish
ratio market comes down bullish ratio
market goes back up bearish ratios the
market starts selling off again I'm not
trying to say it's a red light green
light system but it helps you analyze
the market so you could be on the right
side of the market okay it blends great
market to trade you know people always
ask me hey you know what's the market I
in trade I got a full-time job but I
want to watch the market well wake up in
the morning and trade buns it's a great
contract trades on your ex it starts at
1:00 a.m. Chicago time and 2:00 a.m. is
is the cash open so liquidity really
starts to pick up after 2:00 a.m. but
you know you can trade it from 2:00 a.m.
until 6:00 a.m. if you go to work you
can see here bearish ratio bears ratio
bearish ratio bearish ratio price
rejection are these three right here so
you know as he hit this high you got
signs of price rejection and the market
just sells off naturally so you know
these are the ratios that are in the
order flows trader software so what if
you can't read order flow what you don't
want to read order for people Mike you
know I don't have time to read order
flow I mean gosh it's so many numbers I
don't like numbers I'm a math phobic
number phobic what can you do for me
well that's where this tool the price
rejecter comes in handy and it analyzes
the order flow imbalances and price
action and it works the great thing is
it works on a normal bar chart as well
as the volume footprint chart so this is
the price rejector right oh this is a
normal bar chart okay and when you lay
the price rejector on top of it
voila you see signs of price rejection
signs the price rejection signs of price
rejections signs of price rejection now
people say wall doesn't pick every
single high and low well of course not I
mean come on it's reading the order for
looking for signs of price rejection in
the order flow not every bar is going to
exhibit price rejection there are points
in time when it is exhibited in the
order flow and those are the times that
you got to take advantage of it and a
perfect example is you know people like
take for example this high here okay
well you have the price rejector kick it
in here it comes back up here now I know
a lot of people will say well I got to
get short here well okay the first time
you traded there you have signs of price
rejection and then you sold off through
an area we got signs of price rejection
down here now as you come back up you
got a watch are we getting lesser and
lesser I mean you can put an offer in
here to try and
the ensuing double swing double top and
sell-off but if you're watching the the
order flow you watching the volume and
you see the volume is heavier now than
it was earlier there's a good chance
that it's gonna get through there and
keep going higher because like I said
you know we rejected these prices or
buyers rejected these prices you don't
necessarily know there was strong
sellers there but if you're coming back
up here and buyers are no longer
rejecting those prices things have
changed in the market and we can keep
going higher again you know this is the
price rejecter again on NASDAQ you know
it gets some nice moves in here euro
currency and again you know you got to
watch you know what when you test these
levels again you know is buying still
stronger as buying weaker or selling is
it strong or is it weak you know there's
more than one ways to approach the
market you know everyone always says
well I have a method of trading the
market when it works or it's great when
it doesn't work doesn't work well you
need more than one way you know you got
diversify so to speak rather than just
have one way I mean there's you know if
you have a store
all right selling phone chargers well
you know I can just sell an apple
charger now you got to add you know
Android chargers you got to add some of
these stupid stupid me add some of these
little Chinese phones that have the
other different chargers even Nokia's
got a different charger so you got a
diversify you're gonna add different
product lines and with trading you gotta
have different trade different ways of
analyzing the market different trade
setups this is how it looks on a volume
footprint chart you know you got the
swing high you got the price rejector
right after the stack buying imbalance
you know a lot of people say I got
stacked buying balance I got to buy but
okay if you're watching the order flow
and you have a tool like the price
rejecter you can see well you know
prices are being rejected up here okay
so if I'm wrong they are it would be
very hesitant and instead I'd be looking
to cut my loss as soon as possible
rather than letting myself get stopped
out at a lower price then down here you
got some signs of price rejection first
time you hit this low second time
again you know you still see in some
price rejection in this bar even though
you made a new low okay maybe you got
took a trade here you got stopped out
but then okay
well you know what I still see price
rejection you know sometimes that's how
the market does it doesn't automatically
just turn on a dime sometimes it makes
that one or two last little poke through
before it turns around and puts in the
monster rally so even if you got stopped
out here you still got to take your
trade you know this is the problem that
I see with a lot of traders is they have
a loss okay say they take this trade
here they have a loss and then it's like
also now they're gonna handicap their
trading system they say well I had a
loss so I'm gonna wait for the next
train to be a winner before I get in
well then you're gonna what you're doing
is you're hindering yourself you're
affecting your performance because
you're not gonna take this next trade
because you just suffered a loss
psychologically you know that's what
that comes down to the mental side of
training but you know a lot of traders
you know I had this loss I I don't know
if I trust this method of trading then
what happens is they don't take the next
trade and this is what it looks like you
know that's why you got to have a
trading plan where you can define now
how much you're gonna risk on a trade
and how many losers you know you can
withstand and if it's too much for you
to withstand you got a rewrite redraw
your trading plan so hopefully by now
you can see how powerful order flow
analysis is in determining price
rejection again don't overcomplicate
trading people like to over complicate
things that's human nature you know
whether it's in trading or whether it's
in real life and hopefully if you found
this helpful
you'll really like my overflows trader
2.0 software package and what it is it
consists of the order flows trader 2.0
for mt8 ninja trader 8 it works on ninja
trader 8 it's the volume footprint chart
with seven pre-programmed order flow
indicators already in there you know
people they like to keep selling your
new indicators I don't like the
necessary even though I have additional
indicators I feel it's complimentary for
it you know that's not the whole core
where I say here's the volume footprint
chart now you gotta buy all these
different seven indicators that's why I
put these tools in there so that you
already have tools that you can use in
your trading and you're gonna get my
chart templates so your charts will look
like this
all right I don't want you to sit here
and stare at a blank screen thinking ugh
what do I got to do how do I set this up
you know it doesn't make sense and you
know I said you know we're not all born
in the matrix we don't have chips
implanted in our head that we can figure
out everything there is about computing
you know that's why I throw my chart
template in there so you can get your
chart to look like mine in a few clicks
little you just click copy and paste it
into the chart folder and normally I
sell the software by itself for $8.99
but I realized that having order flow
software is one thing you gotta know how
to use it and that's what bothers me a
lot about you know software vendors you
know it's a slimy business honestly
because people take other people's ideas
put them out as their own and they don't
understand how to use them in the first
place and then it's just you know it's
misinformation and fake news in the
trading world so to speak fake
information and this is what I call it
as I give you additional in the in
education right I want you to understand
order flow I want you to learn how to
trade order flow I don't want to just
give you a fish I want to teach you how
to fish and so what I got is for you is
if you buy the software I give you
access to the order flow trading course
and I sell this normally for $300 to 97
it's 15 hours of video instruction and
it really covers all the bases of
learning order flow okay and you know
people buy this regularly I mean
especially people that have other
trading software you know people that
use sierracharts people that use off and
oft people that use ofa and and you know
some of these other you know go me that
they want to learn order flow they see
it they like I'm interested but it's so
freakin complicated I can't get my head
around it sometimes but I know there's
value in it they get the core so then
you know they're able to understand it
better someone give you access to that
for free but you know again for I know
that you're watching this video this
video this webinar is because you're
really interested in furthering your
knowledge in order flow so I also give
you access to my Oracle inner circle
video series there's 56 videos on
advanced order flow I don't call them
tricks but you know forms of analysis
tips on trading
that you're not gonna get anywhere else
this is proprietary information I
created this inner circle video series
actually for my kids because you know
they're still young my oldest is is
turning six this year and you know if
they want to learn how to trade you know
if anything happens from you or whatever
suffer a stroke or something at least
I'll have this information that they can
go go on to to watch and learn and you
know go from there if they want to learn
how to trade you know hopefully I'll be
able to sit down with them and teach
them but right now they're more
interested in watching peppa pig videos
on YouTube then watching videos on the
market but you know hopefully you know
in time you know this is there for them
to learn how to trade as well so you
know and yeah it's it's also for you you
know so you can learn how to trade you
know that's why I created these these
videos is to expand the knowledge space
that's out there so you know you add up
the software the the training the inner
circle video that's 1693 already it's
the 1693 but you know even because
investor inspiration always invites me
back and i really appreciate the chance
to speak with people it's great because
they've made you know some good
friendships with people honestly that
that I've met through these webinars I'm
gonna give access to the trader
kickstart training which deals with the
mental side of trading it deals with the
psychology of trading you know we don't
understand our own selves you know
people I say you got to do research on
the market you also have to do me search
you know you have to look inwards and
see where your strengths are where your
weaknesses are and develop those and
sometimes it's not so much as taking the
parts that don't work in your trading
and just disregarding them you also have
to take the parts that do work and go
take it a step further from there so
I'll give you access to that normal I
sell that for 297 so you start adding it
up it's almost two thousand dollars it's
1990 1990 dollars but you're not gonna
pay that I can pay anywhere near that
he's gonna pay a one-time payment of
eight hundred ninety nine dollars so you
go to order flows calm slash PR and
take you to the page where you can sign
up there's no more monthly payments I'm
not gonna shake you down in a year say
all you got to pay another yearly fee no
that's it it's $8.99 and you can also
for the next three traders they're gonna
get the price of rejecter tool now the
additional software that runs on the
ninja trader platform so you could put
it on there so you could see these areas
of price rejections in the bars you know
whether you use a bar chart or whether
you know I believe you should it's
better for you as a trader to use a
volume footprint chart but you're gonna
get that for free so you know you're
gonna have another way to increase your
success at trading and again you know
you add all that up it's you know two
thousand two hundred ninety dollars but
you're not gonna pay that again you just
gonna pay $8.99 and you know other
people have said to me you know they've
posted these online Mike your order
flows trader software is remarkably
helpful because I can clearly see now
what's really happening in the market
like for example who's in control of the
market on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well I love the idea
of your ratios printed above or at the
bottom of the bar to gauge of prices
rejected or defended you know there's
other people saying nice things about
the software you know if you take the
time to learn it you know again it's
it's not something that if you think you
just gonna install it on your system and
not you know understand what you're
seeing you know or rather not take the
time to you know read one of the user
guides you know I also give you guides
on how to you know setups to look for or
what things mean in the market I mean
you do have to take some initiative on
yourself you have to want to learn you
know honestly if you just want somebody
if you're just gonna be the type that's
gonna buy it sit back and think okay
computers start spitting out money no
it's not gonna do that and you know I
save yourself the time and energy don't
buy the software but if you really want
to learn how to trade I suggest you buy
the software and you know one of the
things I've even talked about in here
but we have a weekly live group training
session it's live it's like this webinar
well this webinar is also recorded the
weekly training sessions are also
recorded if you're not able to attend
like say you're in Europe
but it's held every Monday night 7 p.m.
Central Time and I get on a call with
screen sharing and you're free to ask
questions you know if you have a problem
setting up your chart I can answer your
those questions there if you got a
question about you know it was a good
broker or whatever anything related to
the markets you can ask and I'll answer
you know let's say hey Mike Gail what
should I look for in Delta I'll tell you
what should I look for in imbalances
I'll tell you what's the what's a good
chart type filling to use I'll tell you
you know that's what it's there for it's
for me
for you to ask questions to me and I'm
there every week so you know where I am
so you can't say a lot Mike I can't
reach you I sent you an email I can't
reach you you know that's where I am I'm
alive there you can talk to me live you
know what other software does that one
of the software offers that so when you
do is you go to order flows comm /p r
dot HTML takes you to this page scroll
down here and you can see here you get
the order flows trader 2.0 for 899 the
trading course the inner circle video
series access to the trader kickstart as
well and for the next three traders then
you get the price rejecter indicator for
anti 8 again you know I'm going to take
this down when the three traders have
signed up so if you still see it you
still got a chance to get it I just
click buy now I want this you know you
have to want it you know in life when
you want something you got to take
action it takes you to PayPal I don't
get your credit card information I don't
want your credit card information
Rather's it's the third party most
people are familiar with PayPal but if
you ever bought anything online you
probably use PayPal most people have a
PayPal account just make sure your
paypal email address is current because
that's where the information after you
buy will be sent to some people like to
buy something through PayPal on an email
address that they don't use anymore than
they complain that they haven't gotten
it does because you haven't checked your
hooks your paypal email address I don't
know that your paypal email address is
different than your normal email address
so please please make sure you're using
your correct email address so go to auto
close comm / PR and again you know why
should you join order flows is because
you can see the power of order flow
analysis and how it can change your
trading
understand what's happening in the
markets you know you're excited to find
low-risk trading opportunities and most
importantly you want a life of freedom
and fulfillment that's why people come
to trading is because they want freedom
you know they don't want to necessarily
be chained to a desk all day long you
know they want fulfilment they want time
to be able to spend with their family
you know honestly I had a good life
working in the corporate world
and but I didn't have the freedom I
didn't have the fulfillment you know
fortunately it was just ironic that I
was in the trading industry and yeah I
made a decent living you know I was able
to you know travel the world and do
things that a lot of people just aren't
but I didn't have that freedom because I
was sort of chained was until I left the
corporate world and training for myself
that I realized what sort of freedom I
have you know I've got three kids now
and you know there's been time with them
as they're growing up send them to
school you know go on vacation with them
is is fantastic you know just a simple
taking them to the Menards shop you know
to buy something for the house is
special to me so I hope you know you can
see how trading can give you that that
freedom and again you know like I said
it's not like some people say ah Mike's
out there just gave me money no I'm not
I really wanted you to help help you
learn how to trade and become successful
in training that's why I do the weekly
live group training sessions so you
could have access to me on a weekly
basis and ask your questions and you
know it's it's I really enjoy it
honestly you know I get people sending
me emails now saying sending me in their
charts during the week saying hey you
know what this is why I picked up in
your weekly session you know show me
some some of the setups and trades that
they've taken and we're successful so
act now go to order flows calm slash PR
and and join so I can you know I can't
stress this enough stop flushing your
money down the toilet people think they
gotta buy everything on trading no you
just gotta be selective in what you buy
buy things that you think are going to
help you in trading so again go now to
order closed comm / PR so thanks
everyone have a great weekend and you
know hope to see you guys on the inside
and see you there in our weekly live
group training session for members on
Monday night so bye-bye